[Musica]
Benvenuta Federica
ragazze
ragazzi
Quante e quanti di voi pensano che
rimarranno tutta la propria vita a Rende
Quanti di voi pensano che studieranno
qua lavoreranno qua magari che un giorno
vivrete nelle case dei vostri genitori
più o meno come me Perché di certo non
lo pensavo io che vengo da una regione
talmente piccola e sperduta che c'è chi
ancora crede che per riuscire a trovarla
basti entrare in un armadio No
ovviamente non è Narnia Ma sì è il
Molise e precisamente Isernia
qui sono cresciuta con una super mamma
single Paola un ex attivista amata e
conosciuta da tutta la comunità
ecco per farvi capire perché da quando
sono piccola ho sempre cercato di
scappare dai Isernia immaginate la scena
ho 14 anni sto camminando per i vicoli
del centro storico di Isernia a fianco
al mio fidanzato di 14 anni e arriva
quel momento in cui ti guardi negli
occhi e sai che vorresti arrivare a quel
fantastico primo bacio
Ma sai anche che in quel momento nei
vicoli di Isernia non ci siete solo tu e
il tuo fidanzato di 14 anni ma ci siete
tu il tuo fidanzato di 14 anni e le 87
vecchiette che ti stanno guardando dalle
finestre di casa loro con il telefono in
mano con il numero di telefono di tua
madre già digitato pronte a chiamarla
qualora la mano di questo ragazzo fosse
finito in qualsiasi altro posto che non
erano le sue tasche Insomma un mix di
Azkaban e Alcatraz dipende dai film che
vi vedete
devo dire però la verità mamma Paola è
sempre stata molto contenta di
assecondarmi nella mia voglia di andare
fuori certo non ho mai capito perché non
mi mandava in gita a Cassino a 40 minuti
di treno da Isernia con i miei amici ma
mi mandava molto felicemente in
Inghilterra all'estero a studiare
l'inglese
ed è così che atterro la prima volta a
Londra ho 13 anni sono sola senza
telefono senza capire o parlare una
parola di inglese in quel momento io
sapevo che sarei dovuta essere sette
terrorizzata
Eppure l'unico modo in cui mi sento in
quel preciso istante è
libera non perché chissà che cosa avrei
dovuto fare ma perché nessuno aveva il
numero di telefono di mia madre e
nessuno la conosceva in quel posto
mi innamoro così di quella sensazione e
aspetto trepidante ogni anno l'estate
per poter prendere e partire Sì sì per
imparare l'inglese ma soprattutto per
poter conoscere me stessa Lontano dagli
occhi e dai giudizi della mia città
mi innamoro a tal punto di questo sogno
che decido di non ascoltare le voci dei
miei genitori che dicono incessantemente
di volermi vedere avvocata
commercialista e decido di studiare
scienze politiche per poter lavorare Un
giorno in una di quelle grandissimi
istituzioni europee che tanto amavo
lontana da Narnia e soprattutto lontana
dazn
inizia così il mio viaggio verso
l'Europa studio politecs filosofi
economics Vado a Bruxelles a fare un
tirocinio faccio la magistratura a
Parigi inizio a lavorare a Copenaghen in
consulenza manageriale per le
istituzioni europee Insomma stavo
realizzando il mio sogno europeo
nel frattempo però l'Europa che conosco
piano piano sta cambiando
qualsiasi tv Io accenda sia a Londra a
Parigi Roma sento continuamente parlare
di Un'Europa ingiusta che vessa i suoi
cittadini con leggi che non vanno bene
con immigrati movimenti atti europeisti
scuotono casa mia fino a farla spezzare
con la brexit sento per la prima volta
che la mia Europa la mia casa sta
crollando e io sono lì a non fare
nient'altro se non a guardare
passa un anno e mentre mi imbarca meno
tra lavori che hanno veramente poco a
che fare con me e tantissimo che fare
con l'ansia di precariato della mia
generazione la situazione non migliora
Io so solo una cosa se resto ferma vado
a sbattere Ma se faccio qualcosa non so
cosa può succedere ma almeno potrò dire
un giorno di averci provato e con una
crisi economica alle spalle un'altra che
sta per arrivare mentre tutta la mia
generazione cerca disperatamente un
posto fisso per potersi fare una
famiglia e poter comprare una casa io
decido di andare completamente
controcorrente lascio tutto lascio un
posto a tempo indeterminato lascio un
ottimo salario lascio le aspettative dei
miei genitori e decido di entrare in
quella cosa che secondo me era alla base
di tutti i problemi
decido di entrare in politica
a inizio così il percorso più
strabiliante della mia vita entro in un
partito fatto da giovani ragazzi e
ragazze europee transnazionale che vuole
cambiare dal basso il modo di fare
politica per portarla di nuovo vicino ai
propri cittadini facciamo centinaia di
campagne di attivismo dal cambiamento
climatico alla partecipazione
Democratica dei cittadini in Europa in
sega Ad Harvard Come fare queste stesse
campagne vivo nelle mie città preferite
tra Milano Londra Parigi e sono
finalmente felice perché sento di nuovo
che sto facendo qualcosa per il mio
sogno per la mia casa la mia Europa fino
a che
ero tornata come fanno molti di noi
pendolari a Isernia per un fine
settimana
bagaglio a mano due paia di jeans due
magliette un computer portatile ero a
casa di mia nonna per il loro
anniversario sto per infilare in bocca
quell'ultimo pezzo di torta alla crema
quello buonissimo Che mangi una volta
sola quando torni a casa che no nonna ti
fa una volta l'anno quando a un certo
punto sento alle mie spalle la voce di
Conte che dice
restiamo tutti a casa
l'Italia è il lockdown
dopo più di 10 anni di vita all'estero
il covid mi blocca in quello che era
stato il mio peggiore incubo nel nulla
più assoluto in cui mi ero ritrovata
quando ero adolescente mi blocca da sola
ai Isernia per 9 oltre per nove mesi non
faccio altro che cercare di capire come
scappare con un diavoletto sulle spalle
che mi ripete Perché non vai su
Skyscanner non trovi un volo per le
Canarie è un angioletto che può avere
allo ogni mattina mi dice Ma dove vuoi
andare che siamo in un lockdown globale
sbatto la testa contro il muro tutti i
giorni fino a che un giorno
ricevo un messaggio di un ragazzo della
mia città e mi scrive Federica Ho visto
che sei a Isernia in particolar modo in
contrada Breccelle E io che stalker
so che hai fatto politica e ti sei
impegnata tanto per l'Europa tra qualche
mese ci saranno le elezioni nella nostra
città ad Isernia e ci sono un gruppo di
ragazze e ragazzi come te come me che
vorrebbero rendere Isernia non soltanto
una città in cui tornare Ma soprattutto
una città in cui restare
ti va di darci una mano
in maniera totalmente inconsapevole
questo ragazzo mi sblocca un ricordo
torno a quando ho 14 anni e con mia
madre sto cercando di fare la valigia
per l'Inghilterra mentre io piego una
maglietta a maniche corte lei cerca di
infilare disperatamente la maglietta di
lana felpata dentro la valigia perché è
vero che va in Inghilterra ad agosto ma
non sai mai che tempo trovi E comunque è
meglio che ti vesti a strati quando a un
certo punto mia mamma mi guarda e mi
dice
Fede credo sia arrivato il momento in
cui io ti dica perché non ti mando a
Cassino con i tuoi amici ma ti mando a
Londra e io beh grazie
devi capire
che piano piano la nostra regione sta
scomparendo
Le nostre aziende stanno fallendo
i genitori dei tuoi amici stanno
perdendo il lavoro e se non vai
all'estero e non impari l'inglese
rischi di scomparire anche tu
e se fino a quel momento avevo sempre
pensato che andare fuori fosse una mia
scelta
capisco che in realtà l'unica cosa che
mi era stata insegnata e che per chi
viene da posti come il mio dove il CAP
che determina il tuo destino
la fuga è l'unica opzione possibile
in Molise ogni anno un ragazzo su due
decide di andare a studiare o a lavorare
fuori
Sapete quanti di questi ragazzi decidono
di tornare a casa
più o meno nessuno le statistiche per il
resto del Sud Italia non sono più
Clementi
ci viene insegnato che in posti come i
nostri la carriera la gloria sono solo
fuori in Europa In quell'europa che è
vero che mi ha fatto da mamma e a cui io
sono davvero grata Ma è anche vero che
costantemente mi ha continuato a
ripetere che tutto ciò per cui valeva la
pena lottare era solo lì fuori senza
darmi neanche la possibilità di aprire
gli occhi a casa mia e capire cosa fare
per poter restare
ed è in questo modo che però la mia vita
si era appunto trasformata in una fuga
da Isernia a Roma da Roma a Parigi da
Parigi a Bruxelles da Bruxelles a Londra
una fuga che non avrei mai fermato Se
non avessi capito che avevo bisogno del
coraggio di andare controcorrente e
capire anziché come scappare Come poter
restare
riprendo il telefono e rileggo quel
messaggio che è vero che mi sapeva molto
di stalking ma mi sapeva anche di
speranza in quel momento e decido di
accettare la sfida inizia così una delle
lotte forse più difficili della mia vita
contro mia madre che mi vedeva senza
futuro contro una marea di uomini di
mezza età che mi vedevano come una
ragazzina dolce e carina ma soprattutto
contro me stessa e quella vocina
costante che mi ripeteva di prendere e
partire come avevo fatto per tutto il
resto della mia vita decido di trovare
un gruppo di ragazze e ragazzi Isernia e
ci candidiamo alle elezioni della mia
città con un programma fatto di sogni ma
soprattutto azioni concrete vinciamo a
Isernia vengo eletta vicesindaca e sono
sbarcata qualche mese dopo sul palco del
Copenaghen democracy Summit dove sono
stata intervistata per più di un'ora da
Barack Obama a raccontare la mia storia
[Applauso]
oggi vivo a Isernia con un gatto un
cavallo e parentesi romantica proprio lo
stalker del messaggio di un anno fa
[Applauso]
ogni giorno lavoro nella mia terra
affinché la storia che raccontiamo i
nostri figli non sia più una storia di
fuga ma una storia di scelta
ragazze ragazzi non abbiate paura di
andare fuori ma non lasciate che andare
fuori di imputa la paura di tornare
perché tornare è tanto difficile quanto
nuotare Controcorrente ma fidatevi Non
c'è cosa più bella che toccare terra e
chiamarla casa grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]